los abogados del expresidente Pedro
Castillo afirman que necesitan más
tiempo para revisar el expediente y
analizar las pruebas que existen contra
el expresidente Pedro Castillo la
fiscalía está pidiendo 18 meses de
prisión preventiva contra castillo y
contra su ex Primer Ministro Aníbal
Torres por los presuntos delitos de
rebelión y conspiración en paralelo a
estos hechos el ex mandatario se negó a
participar de la audiencia de esta
mañana y su abogado Ronald atencio
renunció porque según él no existirían
las condiciones normales para ejercer la
defensa previamente a toda esta
situación Pedro Castillo desde su centro
de detención escribió una carta donde
rechaza a la prisión preventiva y
responsabiliza a los fiscales y a los
jueces por cualquier tipo de situación
que pueda acontecer respecto a su
situación legal y también le pide a la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos que interceda por sus derechos
así las cosas al juez Juan Carlos
chakley no le quedó otra medida que
aplazar la audiencia para mañana a
partir de las ocho y treinta horas Lima
Bogotá bien Francisco y entre tanto Qué
acciones está ejecutando la presidenta
Dina boluarte para detener las protestas
en Perú
diversos sectores del Perú de piden a la
presidenta Dina boluarte que declare el
estado de emergencia nacional ella ha
señalado que está evaluando ordenar la
medida Mientras tanto desde el comando
de manejo de crisis que ha instalado
para atender esta situación crítica ha
declarado el estado de emergencia en los
departamentos de ica y Arequipa y
también ha dispuesto la declaratoria de
emergencia en la red Vial nacional para
proteger los puntos estratégicos del
país y ha dispuesto la movilización de
las fuerzas armadas y tratando de frenar
esta ola de protestas ha anunciado que
las elecciones se van a adelantar a
diciembre de 2023 y ya no va a ser el
2024 como ella había señalado antes sin
embargo las protestas se siguen
produciendo y en esta jornada de hoy se
producen bloqueos en la región de puno
que es fronteriza con Bolivia también en
región junín que es ubicada en el centro
de Perú se está convocando un paro de 72
horas producto de esta jornadas una
persona murió en Apurímac y ya se
contabilizan en siete los muertos en
Perú por esta ola de violencia